[Music]
Lindsay Lohan's ready to be a mama
really happy and just grateful the
actress is the lore's June cover star
inside the mag she opens up about her
excitement about becoming a mother quote
I can't wait to see what the feeling is
and what it's like to just be a mom I'm
like do you see him smiling here I'm so
happy in March Lilo revealed she and
husband Bader shamas are expecting their
first child and while she's taking in
the moment she does admit her emotions
are taking over Lindsay says there are
happy tears that's just who I am though
now it's probably baby emotion it's
overwhelming in a good way I have a kind
heart
um and I'm sensitive I want things to be
perfect also sharing in the baby Joy
Lindsay's loved ones in April friends
and family celebrated the mom to be with
an intimate baby shower mom close with
my family I love them and they love when
I'm here and I love when they come to
see me and we know lilo's Mom Dina is
ready for her newest grandkid in March
she told E.T my baby is having a baby
adding the fam feels blessed and over
the moon in anticipation for our baby
Miracle to arrive I'm just happy and
grateful it's a family affair
lens will be a working mom she's got
multiple projects in the works I love
acting that's never going to stop I'm
always going to act the one that has
fans most excited the follow-up to her
2003 film Freaky Friday don't start with
me and those clothes are going back
first thing tomorrow why Everyone likes
them you look great I look like Stevie
Nicks who's he
ET can't confirm that a sequel is
currently in development at Disney and
both Lindsay and her on-screen mom Jamie
Lee Curtis are in talks to return
[Music]
and Jamie's already sharing advice to
Lilo on juggling mom and afterlife
Lindsay sharing she was like you just
bring the baby with you and everything
will be fine it's so heartwarming when
you get to share that experience with
family and and everyone that becomes
your friends on set it's just a really
it makes it all the much that more worth
it
foreign